[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم للحداثه حكايه طويله في المجتمع
السعودي الحداثه بشقها الادبي والثقافي
وما ينتج على هامشها من صراعات تتعلق
بالاصاله والمعاصره التجديد والتقليد
والمدارس التي تتبنى ذلك النهج في عمليه
الابداع والكتابه والتعبير المعتمد على
التجربه والتطوير وكسر القوالب النمطيه
والثوره على الانماط والاساليب التقليديه
في الاجناس الادبيه في مقابل التشديد على
فكره الاصاله والمحافظه على الاطر
والاشكال الدارجه والخشيه مما يفضي له ذلك
التجديد من هدم للموروث هذا من جانب ومن
جانب اخر الصراع الذي عبرت عنه فكره
الحداثه في الجوانب الاخرى من حياه
المجتمعات المتعلق بالاداره والمجتمع
مكانه المراه وكافه القضايا المرتبطه بذلك
ضيفنا الليله الناقد والمفكر السعودي
البارز الدكتور سعد البازعي احد الفاعلين
في هذا المشهد الغني والتاريخي واهم من
وثقه ون
المؤلفات الثقافيه والفكريه والاكاديميه
وترجمته للعديد من الكتب الهامه يمكنك ان
تتعرف على جانب مهم من المسيره الثقافيه
التي شهدتها المملكه في مراحل عده من خلال
تجربه البازعي وان تفهم التفاعلات التي
قدمت اسماءا واعمالا بارزه على الصعيد
السعودي المحلي وكذلك العربي مشاهدينا
الكرام الناقد والمفكر السعودي الدكتور
سعد البازعي ضيف المقابله في حلقتين فاهلا
ومرحبا بكم
[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا دكتور سعد هلا سعيدين جدا
بوجود الناقد والمثقف والمفكر السعودي
ضيفا على المقابله عاده في بدايه الحلقه
نعود الى بدايه انت ولدت في القريات في
شمال السعوديه
طبعا القريات عزيزه علي عزيز علينا جميعا
لكن الحقيقه كان وجودي وجود والدتي في تلك
الفتره
هو السبب في اني ولدت في تلك المنطقه
وكانت زياره الحقيقه يعني كانت الوالده
والوالد رحمهم الله في الجوف سكاكا
وذهبت هي لاخوها الامير عبد العزيز
السديري كان محافظ الحدود الشماليه يسمونه
ذاك الوقت
بالضبط
وكان هو موجود
فجاءت الولاده في تلك الفتره
وهو اللي سماني على ابن له متوفى اسمه سعد
على الخال اللي سماه اي نعم ولا اسم سعد
غريب على اسرتنا يعني اشرتنا من القصيم من
وين أسم سعد من من بلده اسمها الربيعيه
تبعد 30 كيلو عن بريده
والامراء الصداره نعم السداره من اي منطقه
احمد ابن الغاط يعني
دواسرهم يعني اصلهم من الجنوب
في الاساس يعني وسكنه والغاط
وطبعا الامام عبد الرحمن الفيصل رحمه الله
تزوج ساره بنت احمد السديري اللي تصير عمه
جدي وام الملك عبد العزيز وبالتالي انت
تربطك صرت قرابه بالملك سلمان
رحمه الله عليه والامراء احمد وعبد الرحمن
نعم الله يحفظ الملك سلمان ويغفر للمتوفين
وانا الحقيقه من اتشرف طبعا بهذا الانتماء
يعني شيء اعتز به واذكر على المثقف خاصه
المثقف المنشغل بالاكاديميه وبالناقد
الثقافي والادبي وما الى ذلك
لم يكن له تاثير لا لا ابدا يعني الحقيقه
انا ظليت في الجامعه وضليت فيه ايضا
المؤسسات ثقافيه
وتحظى برعايه يعني انا طبعا صارت علاقتي
بالملك سلمان نتيجه عملي في بعض هذه المؤ
منها النادي الادبي
بالرياضبان اماره لمنطقه الرياض كان امير
منطقه الرياض
ويعني عرفت عن قرب علاقه الملك
الله يحفظه
بالاسره الثقافيه بشكل عام وكانت علاقه
وثيقه ويعرف الجميع تقريبا يعرفوا كتاب
ويعرف الشعراء
واذكر له يعني شيء
اعتقد انه ينبغي ان يشاد به اللي هو انه
كان يتيح لهذه المؤسسات ولهؤلاء الاشخاص
ان يعملوا دون تدخل مباشر ابدا في عملهم
وهذا شيء كان يعني على نقيض ما كان يحدث
في بعض المناطق الاخرى لكن فعلا نحن في
الرياض استمتعنا واستفدنا من هذه العلاقه
الجميله
والحميمه بالملك
توجهت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه 75 75
وش هل هالصدمه اللي صارت يعني 75 مرحله ما
هي مبكره كثير ولكن ايضا مرحله يعني لا
بالنسبه في مرحله يعني يشبه النضج شوي
ومتزوجا ورزقت بابنتين في في امريكا
وجلس سبع سنوات تقريبا ونصف في نفس
الجامعه اخذنا الماجستير الدكتوراه اللي
هي جامعات
ديانا يعني من الجامعات اللي نشات في
منتصف القرن التاسع عشر هذا السعودي
النجدي الذي انتقل في منتصف السبعينات
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ماذا راى هناك
ماذا ماذا يعني ما هي العناوين الرئيسيه
للحياه الاولى في في امريكا كان في صدمه
حضاريه
وكان فيه تصورات مسبقه
اذكر في نيويورك يعني انا وزوجتي كنا
مرعوبين يعني الشوارع والطاطحات سحاب
وفعلا لما دخلنا الفندق فكان في سبع حوالي
سبع اقفال على الباب فكان في شيء يؤكد هذه
الصوره النفطيه يعني او المخاوف لكن لما
ذهبنا الى هذه البلده بلده صغيره اي طبعا
تختلف تماما لكنه
يعني بدات بعض الصعوبات والتحديات من
البدايه انما وجود بعض الطلبه السعوديين
ساعدنا على التاقلم يمكن تسال سعد الصويان
عن سعد ابكر منك اقدم ايه
المرحله الثانويه لا انا رحت يعني
واكبر عمره
درست طبعا تخصص كانت بعدين تروحت
الدكتوراه في الاستشراق في الاداب
الاوروبيه ما الذي يعني اثرك بشكل كبير في
هذه الثقافه الغربيه النظام صراحه مدهش
نظام المروري النظام الناس تنتظم في صفوف
طوابير
تقدم طبعا اللي كان حاصل لما تدخل سوبر
ماركت وتجد العربيات اللي كان ما كانت
موجوده اصلا في ذلك الوقت
طريقه التسوق طريقه البنك البنك التعليميه
الفكريه
تعليميا وفكريا هذه مساله اخرى لانه انا
واجهت الاخر المختلف اللي انشغل فيه
انشغلت فيه بعدين نعم يعني الاخر مختلف
باختلافه
وببعض
السمات التي ازعجتني الحريات الفرديه كانت
اكثر من مره والرجل ما كانت مالوفه
بالنسبه لنا وكان فيه نوع من الاستغراب
لديه لدى زوجتي ايضا يعني
عندما تعاقلم مشهد الحال الحمد لله عاده
بين امرين الانسان يكون لما يدرس في
الولايات المتحده في تلك الفتره اما
الاعجاب ومن ثم الانغماس في تلك الحياه
والرغبه حتى في البقاء نعم نعم ان يسكنوا
هاجس العوده
والمساهمه كان هاجس العوده يطاردني
باستمرار وكنت اخشى ان افقد هويتي
الثقافيه والاجتماعيه دكتور سعد البازعي
في تلك الفتره وبين اسره يعني لها حضورها
من الطبقه
او ما فوق حتى المتوسطه كانت تمت فرص خاصه
مع عمليه النهضه في السعوديه والحداثه
كانت كبيره اقصد تمت فرص على صعيد المناصب
الاعمال الكبرى الاعمال الحكوميه او
التجاريه حتى انت اختطيت مسار اكاديمي
ثقافي ملتزم بشكل كبير جدا شعرت انك فوتت
فرصه ما او انك بالعكس هي هي فيها فرص
فاتت لكنها لكن لما تاسف على فواتها
كانت متاحه يعني يعني سواء في العمل
الحكومي بالضبط لا لا يعني كانت
واضحه امامي تماما يعني اننا نريد فلان ان
ياتي لنا وسنجد له مكان وكذا بهذه العباره
يعني انا بصفه عامه باحث بالدرجه الاولى
باحث
يهمني الكتاب والتاليف والتدريس والعلاقه
بالطالب انا
بهاجس العوده والاسهام الثقافي في مجتمع
بالضبط يتلمس طريقه بشكل كبير جدا كانت
بدايات ايضا نقول ما نسميها معركه الحداثه
والمدرسه التقليديه
نعم وبدات اعي ملامح او ادرك ملامح المشهد
بالتدريج فلما جيت ان غبرت بها فجاه وطبعا
ممن ساهموا في ذلك الناس اللي التقيتهم
بالاكاديميه اللي كانوا بعيدين طبعا
كثيرين كانوا بعيدين انت انخرطت فيها انا
انخرطت بقوه وكان هذا على حساب حتى البحث
العلمي بالشكل الذي يؤدي للترقيات السريعه
يعني فانا لا انا رحت اكتب ثقافه الصحراء
بينما زملاء كانوا يؤلفون او يكتبون اوراق
بحثيه للتحكيم المساعده
فكل هذا الشغل اللي انجزته في ذلك المرحله
ما كان له اي قيمه علميه يعني او اكاديميه
ساتحدث عن المجتمع ستتحدث عنه حتى معركه
الحداثه حاله المجتمع السعودي في مطلع
الثمانينات عوده الاكاديمي والمسكون بهاجس
الحداثه والنقد الادبي بشكل كبير في في
ثنايا حلقتين مع المثقف والناقد والمفكر
السعودي الدكتور سعد البازعي وكرر
الترحيبي حياك الله شكرا لك
قرن من الابتعاث التعليمي بدا ارسال
الطلبه السعوديين الى الخارج لتحصيل
الشهادات العلميه عام
1927 بتوجيه من الملك عبد العزيز ال سعود
حيث جرى ابتعاث 14 طالبا الى مصر ومع
زياده موارد الدوله توسعت البعثات الى
لبنان وبعض الدول العربيه لتكون البدايه
الفعليه الابتعاث الطلبه الى اوروبا عام
1936 بينما تخرجت اول دفعه سعوديه رسميه
في الجامعات الامريكيه عام 52 من القرن
الماضي وضمت تسعه طلاب ثلاثه منهم لدراسه
البكالوريوس وسته لدراسه الماجستير بغيه
مواكبه التقدم العلمي ونقل الخبرات
العالميه الى البلاد جاء عقد السبعينات
مقترنا بتضاعف اعداد المبتعثين السعوديين
الى الولايات المتحده وحدها اذ بلغ عددهم
800 مبتعث عام
1974 ولم
سوى عام واحد ليقفز العدد الى اكثر من
2000 مبتعث لدراسه مختلف التخصصات العمليه
والنظريه اخذ عدد المبتعثين السعوديين في
الاضطراد ليشهد طفره نوعيه في عام 2005
باطلاق برنامج الملك عبد الله للابتعاث
الخارجي والذي عد الاضخم في تاريخ المملكه
وعلى مستوى العالم وبدات الاعداد تصل الى
مئات الالاف في مختلف دول العالم ويقول
القائمون على البرنامج الحالي انه يهدف
لبناء قيادات تساعد في صنع شيء جديد
ومختلف للبلد وتعزز النمو الاقتصادي وتحقق
التنميه المستدامه وترفع كفاءه راس المال
البشري اما مسار الرواد المسار الابرز في
هذا البرنامج ففيه يستهدف البرنامج ابتعاث
الطلاب لافضل 30 مؤسسه تعليميه في العالم
تحقيقا لمتطلبات وطموحات رؤيه المملكه
لعام
[موسيقى]
بعد مشوار دراسي طويل في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه عدت بشهاده الدكتوراه والتحقت
بجامعه الملك سعود استاذ
كان المشهد كيف كان المشهد خلينا نقول في
السعوديه في مطلع الثماليات تعود في 84
انا كنت مهيا للمشهد قبل عودته لانه كنت
على تواصل مع بعض الزملاء في المشهد
الثقافي بعض الكتاب والاعلاميين الذين
كانوا يراسلونني نتيجه انني كنت
انشر وانا هناك انشر مقالات فانت جزء منه
اصلا اثناء وجودك نعم دخلت المشهد وانا
طالب يعني طالب بعثه فلما عدت بدات اتعرف
على المشهد تدريجيا
والحقيقه كانت مبادره مني اكثر منها ان
المشهد جاي الي يعني اذكر اني ذهبت الى
النادي الادبي بالرياض وسلمت على رئيس
النادي الشيخ عبد الله بن ادريس رحمه الله
وذكرت انني فلان وعندي محاضره اريد ان
ابقيها المحاضره كانت حول اطروحتي يعني
كنت راغب في دخول المشهد كان قرارا واعيا
قرارا بالاشتباك او الالتحام سابق تصميم
واراده
فرحب به الحقيقه واعطاني الفرصه وكانت
محاضره يعني اثارت او لفتت الانتباه
بعدها يعني انطلقت هنا وهناك في الجامعه
او في النوادي الادبيه وحتى النوادي
الرياضيه كان هناك ايضا نشاط يعني الكل
يعرف ما جرى في الثمانينات من من صراع على
نقول بين ابناء المدرسه التقليديه
والمدرسه الحدثيه كيف يمكن ان نؤرخ لهذا
المشهد الثقافي في السعوديه مطلع
الثمانينه والله هذا المشهد يعني له عناصر
مهمه يعني اولها هؤلاء اولئك الكتاب من
الشعراء والقاصين والنقاد الذين
والاعلاميين طبعا
الذين عبروا عن انفسهم بنشر اعمالهم وكانت
ردود الفعل مختلفه اذا ما اردنا ان نحدد
طبيعه المواجهه بين المثقفين الحدثيين
سواء كتاب شعراء
قاصين
اعلاميين وما الى ذلك وبين غالبا رجال
الدين صحيح صحيح رجال الدين النشيطين
الفئه المحافظه من الكتاب يعني هناك كتاب
لم يكونوا راضيين عن
قصيده التفعيل مثلا او قصيده شعر الحر
شعر ان هذا التدمير او تخريب للغه وللادب
وللتراث فكان هذه الفئه موجوده ايضا يعني
ليس فقط رجال الدين وانما المحافظون ايضا
من بشكل عام من المثقفين الكتاب كان
المعركه دكتور لم لم تكن فقط ادبيه ثقافيه
كانت يعني لها
ابعاد اخرى صحيح لانه يعني انا اذكر اني
قلت هذا الكلام في ذلك الوقت
عندما نقول قصيده شعر الحر عندما الشعر
الحر
الحريه هنا في
الملتصقه بالشعر لها
ايحاءاتها ليست حريه مرتبطه بالقوالب
والاشكال والانماط انما ايضا حريه
بالمضامين حريه اجتماعيه حريه فكريه يعني
رغبه في تغيير او احداث تغيير في المشهد
الثقافي والمشهد الثقافي جزء من المشهد
الاجتماعي في نهايه الامر لا نستطيع الفصل
بين هذه من رموز تلك المرحله دكتور والله
من الحدثين خلينا نقول رموزها كثيرون يعني
اعتقد انه لابد ان نذكر
شخص مثل محمد العلي الكاتب المعروف وعبد
الله نور رحمه الله ولا بد ان نذكر بعض
رؤساء الانديه المهمين الذين اسهموا مثل
عبد الفتاح ابو مدين في نادي جده الادبي
الذي احتضن هذه الحركه ودعمها
لكن ايضا النقاد طبعا دكتور عبد الله
الغذاامي الدكتور سعيد السريحي
وكان هناك ناس مثل فايز ابا كاتب يعني قد
نسيء ربما نسيه البعض الان لكن ايضا
الشعراء محمد الثبيتي عبد الله الشيخان
محمد الجبر الحربي
وغيرهم كثير طبعا القاصون ايضا كانوا يعني
فاعلون في هذا كانوا فاعلين في هذا المشهد
يعني صالح الاشقر اذكر يعني محمد علوان
ليس محمد حسن محمد علي علوان
وحسين علي حسين الى اخره فالعدد كبير طبعا
عبد العزيز المشهري رحمه الله اسم مهم جدا
في هذه المعادله
علي الدميني محمد الدميني هؤلاء كانوا في
قلب المشهد وبعضهم كانوا محررين في
الصحافه
الادباء او شعراء ومحرم مثل علي الدميني
كان يشرف على صفحات اليوم وانا
ايضا يعني كان له عمل دكتور سعد البازع
جاء من زاويه مختلفه خاصه به من الزاويه
الاكاديميه الموضوعيه النقديه التي تحاول
ان تقرا يعني كان هناك نفس نضالي حتى سواء
عند بعض الحدثين او من في مواجهته كان
مشروع نضالي او او ايدولوجي حتى صحيح
بالنسبه لك الامر كان مختلفا نوعا ما الى
حد ما نعم يعني هذا يعود الى
شخصيتي او انتمائي للاكاديميه للمؤسسه
الجامعيه من ناحيه ومن ناحيه اخرى اعتقد
انها عود الى طبيعتي الشخصيه يعني انا
اميل للاعتدال والهدوء يعني لستم من
يستفزون بسهوله او
حادين في ردود الفعل يعني انا لا طبعا لا
ادعي المثاليه في هذا الوضع طبعا كان ايضا
خصومات وخلافات مع بعض الحدثين انفسهم
يعني وليس دائما الحداثيين ضد التقليديين
حتى الحداثيين كان في نوع الخلاف في وجهات
النظر وانا اعتز الحقيقه انني كنت اختلف
حتى مع بعض الزملاء في بعض الاراء
وكان البعض يرى انه هذا ما يضعف هذا
التوجه
لكني لا اؤمن بذلك انا اعتقد انه كان
يمنحه مصداقيه اكثر
وان المساله ليست ايديولوجيه او تحجبات
وانما هي رغبه في احداث تغيير بناء ونحن
صادقون مع انفسنا او ينبغي ان نكون كذلك
ما هي القضايا التي شكلت يعني حاجزه لديك
في بدايه التحامك بهذا المشهد وفي ايضا
خضم الجدل الكبير الذي كان حاصلا في تلك
والله في الواجهه طبعا هو التغيير الادبي
هذا هذا الواضحه نعم
والادب يمس شخصيه الامه شخصيه الثقافه هو
في القلب يعني عندما تغير في انماط
الكتابه في اللغه الكتابه عندما تستخدم
الاساطير او الرموز تبدا الامور تتغير
بالنسبه لكثيرين ويرون ان هناك قطيعه
والبعض استخدم عبارات مثل هذه قطيعه مع
الماضي الى اخره يعني يتتبعون خطى بعض
الكتاب العرب الذين يرونهم نماذج فهذه
كانت في قلب المشهد لكن دخول بعض
المتشددين
يعني اثار مساله العلاقه بالعقيده بالدين
فدخل الدين من هذه الزاويه
واتهم البعض في عقيدته وفي يعني في دينه
بصفه عامه وكان من المؤسف ايضا ان تدخل
المؤسس الدينيه وليس الاشخاص يعني يعني
كتب نشرت في ذلك الوقت ودعمت
من حسن النيه في اعتقادي يعني ليس يعني
للثوابت بالضبط يعني طبعا تهمه التغريب
كانت مطروحه بقوه كانه المعركه الحدثيه في
السعوديه منتصف الثمانينات اخذت بعدا اكبر
من البعد الادبي والثقافي في حدود
المعقوله بالتاكيد
يعني انا من الناس الذين قالوا يعني في
احدى اللقاءات ان الحداثه لها بعدها
الفلسفي ايضا يعني ليست مساله يعني ادب
فقط وثقافه وانما الحداثه هي رؤيه للعالم
يعني انت انت تغير رؤيتك للناس للحياه
للتاريخ للغه للثقافه الى اخره فهي ليست
مساله انه غير القصيده شكل قصيده او شكل
قصه وانما هي تغيير في الرؤيه من الاساسيه
والبعض كان ينفي ذلك ويرى ان المساله ليست
سوى ادب
ابدوا لي انه نوع من الحمايه كانت ولكن
المساله الادبيه لم تكن كذلك ابدا لم تكن
كذلك هل يمكن فهم هذه المعركه بشكل
استثنائي عن تعرف معركه الحداثه والتقليد
الاصاله والمعاصره
وكل هذا كل هذه الامور هي هي حاله عاشتها
دول كثيره يعني صحيح سواء عربي او حتى غير
عربي صحيح هل تمت خصوصيه سعوديه لهذه
المعركه اعتقد على مستوى الخليج على الاقل
الجزيره العربيه والخليج كان هناك تداخل
قوي يعني انا من الناس الكتابي الاول
ثقافه الصحراء تحدث عن الحداثه في البحرين
وفي الامارات وفي قطر وفي الكويت وفي
السعوديه على اساس انها ملتحمه ببعضها
وكان يعني يساعد مثل قاسم حداد حاضر بقوه
في السعوديه يعني معروف ويؤثر وكان
الشعراء السعوديون يذهبون الى البحرين
ويلقون قصائد والى اخره يعني التداخل كان
قوي كان هناك تلمس للم للتراث الشعبي ايضا
وهذا اعطاه سوى مختلفه بالمناسبه يعني
وهذا اسس فكره كتاب ثقافه الصحراء بالضبط
لانه انا اكتشفت ان القصيده
السعوديه او في الخليج بصفه عامه قصيده
متجذره ومرتبطه بحتى الشعر النبطي
بالحكايات وبالتراث وكان كنت اسعى من خلال
هذا الربط الى ان اعطي هذا التغيير
مشروعيه او شرعيه انه هذا لم ياتي من
الخارج يعني انها ليست نبته غريبه وانما
هي ابنه في مواجهه تهمه التغريب بالضبط
ثقافه الصحراء اعتمد على فكرتين اساسيتين
الموروث والمساله ايضا الشفهيه بالتاكيد
الشفهيه كانت تلعب دور كبير ما هو تاثير
الشفهيه في مساله هذه هذا الموروث الثقافي
لدينا الاعباء الجزيره العربيه
طبيعه الشعر او التراث الشعبي معظم
الشفاهي فيما بعد لكنه لم يكتب او لم ينظم
او يؤلف
للكتابه وانما هو شفائي بطبيعته
فالشعر حتى القصيده الحديثه والى حد ما
القصه كانت تعتمد كثيرا على الالقاء يعني
الامسيات الشعريه الامسيات كثيره منتشره
فالجانب الالقائي
اعطى لبعض هذه النصوص جانبا شفاهيه وصار
هناك تلقي على مستوى الشفاهي قلل من الناس
يقراون النص سيستمعون اليها ويتفاعلوا
معها بالسماع هذا اعتقد انه كان له اثر
حتى الدكتور يعني ينظر احيانا بشكل يعني
بشكل او او بنظره دونيه للثقافه الجزيره
العربيه لانها ليست ثقافه مدونه تاريخيا
بعكس ثقافه الاخرى كانت هناك التدوين
التدوين حديث على الثقافه العربيه ككل
يعني نحن نعلم انه يعني الثقافه العربيه
المعاصره والحديثه التدوين طبعا بدا في
القرن الثاني الهجري قديما ايام ظهور
الحضاره العربيه الاسلاميه لكن جاءت فتره
الخمول هذه التي امتدت لقرون يعني اثناء
العصر العثماني مثلا كان هناك جاهل في كل
المنطقه العربيه ولم يكن هناك كتابه او
تدوين بدات مع عصر النهضه في القرن التاسع
عشر او نهايه القرن الثامن عشر والتاسع
عشر امتدادا الى العشرين نهضت المناطق
العربيه
تدريجيا يعني وظهر الكتاب والمترجمون الى
اخره منطقه الجزيره العربيه لاحقت بهذا
الركب متاخرا قليلا
لكن على تفاوت يعني
يعني ابراهيم العريض في البحرين كان يعني
معاصرا للحركه الحداثيه الشعريه في العراق
وله مراسلات مع نازك الملائكه وما الكتاب
العراقيين واللبنانيين
وايضا في السعوديه محمد محمد حسن عواد
وحمزه شحاته كانوا ايضا على اتصال بمصر
وكان هناك تفاعل مستمر
فبدا التدوين انا اعتقد في اربعينات
وثلاثينيات القرن العشرين عندنا في
السعوديه ظهرت اول روايه تقريبا في
الثلاثينيات القرن العشرين
ظهر الشعر ايضا مدونا مكتوب ملاحق ثقافيه
صحف صحيفه ام القرى ظهرت فرد فتره مبكره
عاده هذه المعركه يفترض ان تنتهي بالنسبه
للحدثين بتحقيق واحد من اهم الاهداف وهو
حريه الابداع الى اي مدى حققت يعني
هذه المعركه للحداثيين شعراء ورواه وقاصين
وكتاب ومثقفين هدفهم هذا
الحريه دائما نسبيه يعني لا يمكن لا ننسى
هناك حريه مطلقه او تحققت يعني نستطيع ان
نقول تحققت الحريه في اي مكان في العالم
اصلا يعني لكن يعني اتسعت قبل ذلك وما بعد
ذلك نعم ما نعتقد ان المساحه التسعت
الهامش التسع يعني
استطاع الناس ان يقولوا فيما بعد اكثر ما
كانوا يستطيعون ان يقوله فيقولوا في
البدايه
لكن يعتقد ان هذا جاء بعدما فقدت الحركه
وجهها صارت يعني دخلت في التيار الثقافي
العام لم يعد احد يحتج على قصيده نثر مثلا
او على قصيده تفعيل او على رموز كتاب
رمزيه يعني
فصارت جزء من التيار الثقافي العام كان
هناك حاجه الى شيء جديد ياتي ونعتقد هذا
الشيء الجديد جاء في التسعينيات مع ظهور
الروايه لان الروايه جاءت بشيء مختلف عن
القصيده والقصه القصيره
يعني الحريه اتسعت مع الروايه بشكل خاص
لان الروايه لا يمكن ان تكتب
مع قيود صارمه يعني لان الروايه يفترض ان
تتسع المجتمع تعطي صوره بانوراميه
لعناصر الاجتماعيه لكن ايضا صاحب هذه
مشاكل يعني روايه غازي القصيبي مثلا لم
يفسح لها الا قبل سنوات قليله
وزيرا لا ولان موضوعاتها كانت حساسه يعني
شقه الحريه اصلا من عنوانها يعني ترى
الاشكاليه التي
تطرحها مثل هذه الروايه والروايه الاخرى
طبعا روايه ترك الحمد وغيره ممن ظهروا في
تلك المرحله
[موسيقى]
تاريخ من المسجلات الثقافيه بدات النشاطات
الفكريه والثقافيه في السعوديه على يد جيل
من الصحفيين والكتاب منذ نهايه الخمسينيات
من القرن الماضي فكتب رواد هذا الجيل في
الحداثه والشعر والادب وانتقدوا في
الصحافه ما راوه من مشكله المجتمعيه اوجد
هذا النشاط سجالا دينيا وفكريا بين
التياري الاصاله والمعاصره فبرز كتاب
ممتاز بالجراه في الطرح واثاره الجدل في
مختلف القضايا الفكريه اما الطرف المقابل
في هذه السجلات فتمثل غالبا في رموز
التيار السلفي باتجاهاته المختلفه والتي
ترسخ حضورها في المجتمع السعودي منذ
اربعينيات القرن الماضي وبعد مرحله الرواد
في الستينيات شهدت السعوديه حراكا ثقافيا
مهما خلال السبعينيات تميز بالمسجلات
الفكريه في عام
1975 تقدم عدد من الادباء بمقترح شيء
انديه ادبيه لقيت الفكره قبولا وموافقه
فانشات انديه في كل من الرياض ومكه
المكرمه والمدينه المنوره وجازان وتبارت
هذه الانديه في اصدار سنوف شتى من كتب
ومجلات ضمه اعمال الكتاب والمفكرين
والادباء والباحثين
مثلت العقود الثلاثه الممتده من
السبعينيات حتى التسعينيات من القرن
الماضي حقبه غنيه خاصه في الادب النسوي اذ
انتجت روايات نسائيه سعوديه تميزت بالجراه
والخوض في القضايا الاجتماعيه المختلفه
وكانت في منطقه الصراع الحداثي التقليدي
بين مدرستين ارادت كل منهما ان يكون
المجتمع والثقافه وفق مقاييسها الخاصه
ماذا يجب اليوم على وجه التحديد الثقافي
الذي يجري اليوم او في قلب المشهد اليوم
هو الحراك الذي تقوده وزاره الثقافه في
السعوديه لا شك وزاره الثقافه يعني حلت
محل الدور الذي كانت تقوم به الانديه
الادبيه وجمعيه الثقافه والفنون لوحدها في
ذلك تلك المرحله
الجامعات كانت تلعب دور كبير في
السبعينيات لكن انسحبت تماما يعني اليوم
ليس لها دور كبير يعني مع الاسف غابه
الجامعات الانديه الادبيه
الان وزاره الثقافه ب 11 هيئه
يعني تشمل كل وجوه الثقافه تقريبا
المعروفه حسب التصنيف اليونسكو
وفي طليعه هذه الهيئات هيئه الادب والنشر
والترجمه التي تعد اكبرها
انا عضو منشيه الاداره ويعني عايشت تطور
هذه الهيئه ومنجزاتها ليست مثاليه مئه
بالمئه
رئيس التنفيذي اديب وروائي من ابرز
الروايه العرب اليوم من حيث نفخر به محمد
حسن علوان وشعب ايضا وشاب
ومؤهل ايضا
لعمليه تسويق ثقافه لانه هذا تخصص الاساسي
فوجود هيئه للادب والنشر والترجمه
وبهذا الفريق من الادباء ومن المثقفين
ماذا تفعل على يعني ما اثرها على على
المشهد الثقافي السعودي على وجه التحديد
هو متعدد الحقيقه الاثر اذا لو نظرنا الى
الجانب الادبي لوجدنا انه الهيئه
د
بعده برامج او قدمت برامج ومبادرات منها
الشريك الادبي اللي هو استنهاض المقاهي
بتتحول لمقاهي ثقافيه
فبدا حراك في مختلف مدن ومناطق المملكه
الصغيره والكبيره
فنجد الادباء يحاضرون ويلقون شعر بدعم من
هذه الهيئه البرنامج يدعم تحول المقاهي
الى بقاهي ثقافيه ايضا هناك هناك
المعتزلات الادبيه برنامج مختلف
يتيح للكتاب ان ينجزوا مشروعاتهم في اماكن
توفر لهم العزله والراحه وهذه ايضا مدعومه
وايضا الالتقاء بالكتاب اجانب يدعون الى
المملكه
ايضا اتيح للكتاب السعوديين نحضروا
فعاليات ويقيموا فعاليات في تونس وفي
اماكن مختلفه
عمان والى اخره بدعم من الهيئه يعني هذا
الذي كان تقوم به الى حد ما وزاره الثقافه
والاعلام سابقا والنوادي الادبيه
مبادرات كثيره طبعا على مستوى الترجمه
هناك برنامج ضخم مترجم
منذ بدايه الثمن منذ عودتك وحصولك على
شهاده الدكتور
يعني وهذا يعني يعني الترجمه المباشره
وكنت دائما اشعر بالذنب انني تاخرت في
المساهمه على الرغم من تخصصي ساتي في
الحلقه الثانيه
نشاطك والكتب التي ترجمتها
لكن الترجمه عمليه في غايه الاهميه دكتور
اذا كانت الهيئه تعنى ايضا بعمل الترجمه
هل تمت تحول نوعي في مساله الترجمه في
اتجاهاتها في دعمها خصها انه تعرف عمليه
النشر احيانا والترجمه مكلفه وعوائدها
ايضا على المترجمين ودور النشر ليست
بكبيره جدا صحيح
في الهيئه برنامج عنوانه ترجم
هذا البرنامج يدعو يعني دور النشر
والمترجمين الى ان يتقدموا باعمال يريدون
ترجمتها فتتكفل الهيئه بدعم هذه المشاريع
بعد الاطلاع عليها ويعني اجازتها من حيث
القيمه ومن ناحيه يعني الاعتبارات
المختلفه
قاربنا الان تقريبا حوالي الف كتاب يعني
لسنا بعيدين عن الالف كتاب خلال الاقل من
ثلاث سنوات تقريبا سنتين عدد الكتب تقريبا
وفي مختلف قطاعات المعرفه وليست فقط في
الادب مثلا وفي وانما هناك كتب
في الفلسفه كتب في العلم الاجتماع كتب
يعني
متنوعه وانا شخصيا له علاقه مباشره بهذا
البرنامج من حيث انني اطلع على الكتب التي
تقدم للهيئه هنا الدوله اصبحت فعل ثقافي
بارز دكتور نعم راعي ثقافي لكن لاحظ انه
وله عيوب واحده اي صحيح بس هو الحقيقه نعم
الهيئه
تعي هذه المشكله الاحتمالات يعني انك
عندما تتدخل
ستؤثر بطريقه ايجابيه وسلبيه ربما ايضا
لكن
اذا كنت ستقدم دعم فلا بد ان تتدخل يعني
لا يمكن تقديم دعم لاي شيء
سواء لاسباب
رقابيه او لاسباب ترشيديه يعني ترشيد
العمليه بحيث انه لا تترجم كتب تافهه مثلا
او كتب لا قيمه لها او كتب مخالفه للتوجه
او كتب مخالفه يعني هذه كلها اعتبارات
مهمه واعتقد لكن للمشهد الثقافي الفائده
اكبر يعني تراها انه بمعنى عاده العاملين
في المشهد الثقافي يستحثون الاجهزه الدوله
للدعم عمليات الترجمه التاليف دعم العمل
الثقافي غير يعني غير مربح ماديا عوائده
صعبه وبالتالي ان لم يكن هناك دعما لا
يمكن الاستمرار بشكل كبير صحيح ولكن هناك
خطوره من قضيه يعني الاقتراب كثيرا من قبل
الاجهزه الرسميه يبحث الحدود وسقف الحريات
والتوجهات وما الى ذلك صحيح هناك توجه
الان الى الغاء الرقابه
تماما وجعلها رقابه تاليه يعني مع ان
الكتاب ينشر واذا كانت هناك مشكله
وايضا يعني اعتقد انه انه
نحن الان بصدد وانا ادعو اليه بشكل شخصي
او دعوت اليه ان يكون ان لا تكون الترجمه
يعني عمليه تلقي
لدى الناشرين او المترجمين وانما مبادره
ايضا ينبغي للهيئه ان تبادر بمعنى تطرح
تطرح مواضيع بالضبط تشعر كتب قد يتجاهل
المترجمون وتدور النشر
صعوبتها او ضخامتها او انها من اللغات
يعني لا يعرفها الكثيرون فهذا يعني لا
ينبغي ان تترك هذه الاعمال ينبغي ان يكون
هناك مساهمه طرح اعمال
ويقال ترجموا هذه في مساله الانفتاح
الثقافي التي تعيش المملكه اليوم بشكل
لافت واضح حضرت المفاهيم جديده كانت غايبه
على المشهد المحلي السعودي الفلسفه
الموسيقى السينما المسرح بشكل كبير وبشكل
رسمي اصبح جزء من عمل الهيئات الرسميه
الاهتمام بهذه
المجرات كيف حدث هذا التحول
حدث بانشاء هيئات تعنى بهذه القطاعات
وتنظمها
وبالفعل يعني نحن الان نشهد يعني انشاء
معاهد لتعليم الموسيقى
نشهد الامر لم يكن متاحا قبل الموسيقى
اصلا كانت مشكله بعد ذاتها وجود مساله حتى
شرعيه من ناحيه شرعيه اعتراض عليها من
الاشياء غير موجوده في المناهج غير موجوده
النشاط الموسيقي الان هناك تعاون بين هيئه
الموسيقى ووزاره التعليم هناك هيئه
للموسيقى هيئه للموسيقى
ووقعت اتفاقيات مع
مع وزاره التعليم لتعليم الموسيقى وارسل
الاف الاشخاص للدراسه في الخارج الان
وهناك الاف يدرسون المسرح خارج المملكه
ايضا وسيعودون لتدريس ماده المسرح
والاشراف على النشاط المسرحي في المدارس
فهذه كلها الان تتسرب الى التعليم المساله
ليست لن تكن نشاط نخبوي او ترفيهي ستكون
جزء من العمليه التعليميه وهذا اعتقد انه
اهم ما يحدث الان يعني البعض طبعا تعرف
لديه موقف وتحفظ من هذه المساله لاسباب
شرعيه تعتقد ان الامر تاخر كثيرا خاصه في
مساء مثل الموسيقى مساء يعني تكون طبيعيه
في مجتمعات لا تاخر كثيرا ولكن ان تاتي
متاخر خير الا تاتي الفلسفه دكتور انت
حينما كنت تراس النادي الادبي كنت ترى
نشاطا فلسفيا في حدود ضيع فيما اصبح هناك
ناديا جمعيه جمعيه جمعيه الفلسفه
عندما كنت رئيس النادي قبل يمكن 15 سنه او
كذا
عرفت ان هناك جماعه من شبان سعوديين
يعيش تبعون ويقراون كتب ويناقشونها دعوتهم
للنادي فدخلوا المؤسسه لاول مره
وعمله يعني نشاط دوري اسبوعي يلتقون فيه
بعد مجيء وزاره الثقافه دخلت هذه تحولت
الى جمعيه هذه الخليه من الشباب والمجموعه
تحولوا الى جمعيه رسميه وصارت تدعمها
دعم قوي وعملت حتى الان مؤتمرين دوليين
للفلسفه وهناك كتب تنشر وانك مجله في
الزمانات الدكتور كنت تعاني حتى من
استخدام المفهوم يعني لا يجوز تدريس ماده
الفلسفه صحيح حتى في الجامعه صحيح كنت
استخدمها الدرس لطلبه الدراسات العليا
بشكل متحايل بالضبط
وانا اعتز بانني ربما اكون درست اول ماده
فلسفه يعني في الجامعات السعوديه لانه
اردنا ان ندخل الفكر الحديث عند الطلاب
الطلاب الدراسات العليا لا يعرفون
هيجل وكانت وارستو افلاطوني حاجه مخجئه
لماذا يجب ان يعرفوا هذه لانها لانه
يدرسون الاداب الغربيه
طبعا خاصه في اقسام خاصه باللغه
الانجليزيه الذي اقصده
فهذه الاداب
والافكار النقديه التي غذتها تاسست فلسفيا
يعني لا يمكن ان تفهم النقد العربي الحديث
على فكره القديم والحديث دون ان تعرف كتاب
فن الشعر الارست لان النقاد العرب القدامى
قراوا ارسطوه ترجموه واستفادوا منه فانت
لا تستطيع ان تنفصل عن التراث العالمي
خاصه الاوروبي يعني في هذا السياق فانشانا
ماده اسمها تاريخ الفكر الغربي وكانت
سحايل على العنوان بدل ما نقول تاريخ
الفلسفه وسميته الفكر تمشي تمشي الامور
احيانا بهذه الطريق ما اثر مثل هذا
الانفتاح اليوم على المجتمع على المشهد
الثقافي بشكل خاص والمجتمع بشكل عام الاثر
يحتاج وقت حتى يقاس يعني نحن يعني لدينا
مؤشرات نستخدمها مؤشرات القياس كما
يسمونها لكن يعني الوقت مبكر لمعرفه الاثر
الترفيه
واضح يعني الجانب الترفيهي الانفتاح
الاجتماعي واضح لا يحتاج الى قياس انت ترى
الناس في الاسواق المراه بالذات حققت
مكاسب غير عاديه
يعني ليس فقط في قياده السياره وما الى
ذلك وانما في حريه الشخصيه المثقفه ماذا
استفادت من هذا الامر وانت دكتور يعني
مهتم ايضا بادب المراه منذ فتره طويله جدا
المراه
الحاضره في كل الفعاليات
امراه تدير جزء من اداره هيئه الادب
والهيئات الاخرى يعني نسبه عاليه من
النساء يعملن الان في الهيئات المختلفه
وشابات سعوديات وبعضهم مؤهلات تاهيل عالي
المشرفه مثلا على نشاط ترجمه سيده
الدكتوره هيلر خلف يعني استاذ الترجمه في
جامعه الاميره نوره
فهذا الحراك جزء منه نسائي الى حد كبير
وجزء منه يتوجه الى المراه
هي حاضره بقوه في كل الفعاليات الغذاامي
له راي مثير يا دكتور
يقول فيه ان المحافظه سمه عربيه عموما
واسلاميه خصوصا والعرب راوا في السعوديه
جوهر المحافظه ولم يفكروا بالحثور على
الحداثه فيها لذلك بعض دعاه الحداثه بذلوا
جهدا مقدسا حتى لا يتحول المجتمع السعودي
الى الحداثه لذلك ان الحداثه حكايه خاصه
في هذا البلد
ولاحظ يعني وانا اراقب ردود الفعل حول ما
يجري في السعوديه ان ثمه من يريد للسعوديه
شيء يتصوره هو
ويتخيله وينطبق مع حديث بمعنى انا اريد ان
تكون هذا البلد ان يكون هذا البلد وفق هذا
الشكل وفق هذا النسق وفق هذه المنظومه لا
يتم التعامل مع المجتمع على انهم مجتمع
لديه احتياجاته وتطلعاته ورغباته وما الى
ذلك للدرجه
ان الذي يشاهد سينما في بلد مجاور
للسعوديه يشعر بالالم اذا اذا كانت هناك
سينما في السعوديه او اذا شاهد مسرح وربما
يفتخر بوجود مسرح في في بلدان مجاور
السعوديه عربيه ومسلمه
ينزعج من وجود مسرح في السعوديه او اذا
شاهد احتفاليه ماء وما الى ذلك انا بعيدا
عن الجدل الحاصل الجدل المجتمعي كمثقف
سعودي بارز وكناقد تابع هذه العمليه تبع
تطور مجتمعه مجتمع السعودي كيف تنظر لهذه
المساله
سميتها في يوم من الايام الاستشراق العربي
واعتقد انه في هذا التحيز الذي يشبه
الاستشراق الغربي تجاه الثقافه العربيه
والمنطقه العربيه بل اسيا باكملها والشرق
هو تحيز مؤسف يعني وناتج عن صوره نمطيه
تكرست مع الزمن
وربما نحن اسهمنا ايضا في تكريسها يعني
لحد كبير يعني في فتره من الفترات يعني
كنا سعوديه بالاساس هي في الاساس موجوده
ليست مخترعه لكن المشكله هي في عدم
الاستعداد او او ضعف الاستعداد
لرؤيه الاختلاف والتغير عند البعض وليس
الكل طبعا هناك من بالعكس يعني رحب وراء
هذا التغير يعني قيم هو اعطاه المكان التي
يستحق لكن هناك من يصر يعني على وتراه حتى
في الدهشه
يعني انا اذكر ان احد الشعراء السعوديين
الشعر صديق عبد الله زيد الله يرحمه ذهب
الى العراق واراد ان يقابل جبر ابراهيم
جبره ايضا كاتب كبير وشاعر يعني ومترجم
روايه يعني بالدرجه الاولى
فذهب اليه في بيته يعني يسلم عليه ويتعرف
عليه
فاخبره انه تخرج من جامعه كذا في السعوديه
وهل لديكم جامعات السعوديه وهذا هذا تكرر
عند الباط يعني
فهي الصوره النمطيه في نهايه الامر انت لا
تريد ان ترى غير ما في ذهنك وبالمناسبه هي
تنسحب احيانا يقول الخليج يعني الخليج كذا
او الخليج كذا يعني بصوره عامه لكن
السعوديه تظل هي القلب يعود سؤال الخصوصيه
السعوديه دكتور هل ثمه اليوم في في فتره
الانفتاح هل تمت خصوصيه سعوديه يعني هذا
مصطلح كان رئيسيا في
مفهوم الخصوص مفهوم ملبس جدا يعني انا
اعتقد ان من الطبيعي لكل ثقافه ان يكون
لها شخصيتها فلنقل يعني ليس بالضروره
خصوصيه لا لا ملامحها العامه الاساسي
السعوديه تطرح الخصوصيه مساله تتعلق
بالجانب الديني وجود الحرمين الشريفين
ومساله المحافظه في في نجد بشكل رئيسي وفي
الاوساط القبليه المحيطه بها هو هذه
المكونات الاجتماعيه والثقافيه موجوده
يعني في السعوديه وفي غير السعوديه هناك
خصوصيه للثقافه في مصر خصوصيه للثقافه في
العراق يعني لما كذب طه حسين عن شخصيه مصر
عن مصر اقصد يعني وانها لها تراث الفرعوني
الى اخره او كتب جمال حمدان شخصيه مصر
كتابه الشهير يعني يتحدث عن خصوصيه لثقافه
البلد واعتقد ان كل بلد عربي له هذه
السمات لكنها لا تلغي الابعاد العربيه او
الاسلاميه او والانسانيه الانسانيه طبعا
بالتاكيد انما المشكله هي في توظيف هذه
المفاهيم توظيف سياسي او ايديولوجي دكتور
سعد البازعي الناقد والمفكر السعودي شكرا
جزيلا لك خصصنا هذه الحلقه في معظمها
للنقاش في الجوانب المتعلقه بالمجتمع
السعودي بصير يتكذاتيه وبعودتك وتدريسك
ومشوارك الاكاديمي والثقافي ايضا طويل
والمشهد الثقافي السعودي في مرحلتين مرحله
الثمانينات وما تعيشه المملكه اليوم في
الاسبوع القادم ان شاء الله سيكون نقاش
حول قضايا اوسع قضايا قضايا الهويه
والعولمه والحداثه وما يتفرع منها من
قضايا ملحه كثيره تناولتها في كثير من
مقالاتك وابحاثك وكتبك وايضا بعض ترجمات
شكرا جزيلا لك العفو
الشكر موصل لكم مشاهدينا الكرام على طيب
المتابعه القاكم ان شاء الله الاسبوع
المقبل دمتم بخير وفي امان الله
انا ديمه زرقاء تكتظ بالدمى فتجلو سواد
الماء عن ساحل الظما على قمرا يحمر في غره
الدجى
ويهمي على الصحراء غيثا وانجما
فنكسوهم من احزاننا البيض حله
ونتلوا على ابوابه سوره الحمى
الا ايها المخبوء بين خيامنا
ادمت نطال الرمل حتى تورما ادمت نطال
الرمل فاصنع له يدا ومد له في حانه الوقت
موسمه